[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by cash app and every
time we go from the intro song to the
[ __ ] show in the beginning of the
show every single time one fire goes in
three two one and every single time it
reminds me of when they do it in Wayne's
World and I don't know why but I do
because he goes three two and he doesn't
say one because that might that might
get caught on tape
it might get caught on the show about
what one fire does because he's one fire
he says the one because he doesn't give
a [ __ ] and it's fine because it's a
little it's a little treat for you guys
right it's a little treat for you guys
if you hear one fire ago one then it's
all good but if you don't cuz he
probably takes it out cuz you just sound
engineer my babies then it's all good
man but it you know we got the new arm
we got the new [ __ ] arm in the
congratulations podcast [ __ ] and the
arms not gonna sink anymore it won't
sink anymore it won't sink it'll stay
put because we got the Joe Rogan arm
baby we got the same one Joe Rogan has
because we're coming I'm coming
and we're ready against the spine inside
and every note was the same [ __ ] it up
all good you ever hear a guy who [ __ ]
sings and every note is the same that
guy's got to stop singing and that guy
is my brother my brother can't sing for
[ __ ] and it's all good but yeah so let's
just go over some let's do some how
about one [ __ ] radio now just like
let's pay some bills here let's look at
your let's pay some bills no don't say
it stop being cute about it we got Santa
Barbara coming up and every time I look
at it I think of
para para for some reason looks like
there's one too many a's all good [ __ ]
should there be three a's in one word no
is there yeah or a lot of them cities
yeah is I was gonna [ __ ] with me until I
die
yeah yeah Santa Barbara October 12th
Riverside October 17th that's sold out
San Diego 18th October 19th and October
19th again and I think I have two or
three or four shows in San Diego I don't
remember some of them are sold out and
then I have a Foxwoods Connecticut
November 1st November 2nd Bethlehem
Pennsylvania two shows there
oh sorry hold on I'm gonna do something
here yeah two shows there oh this isn't
working the sound plan isn't working
great great one fire yes all we did is
two things and it didn't work
yes sometimes not working I'm hittin
Pete that's supposed to go Ching and
didn't work yes do any of them work no
just try to hit clap back my droll rule
doesn't work yes oh one fire just goes
okay Oh
socata red-handed knows what he did so
anyway Wow he literally just went and he
goes okay so it's gonna be a good one
and we are gonna fly by the seat of our
[ __ ] diapers today babies that is
what we are going to do because we don't
give a [ __ ] we have one note we have one
note on our notes to talk about and it's
gonna be a story that's about four
minutes long what are we gonna do for
the rest of the [ __ ] 34 56 minutes
we're gonna fly by the seat of our
diapers and then one fire after the show
or Ivan get rid of is gonna be like what
should we call the show and I'm gonna
try to remember well we should call it
fly by the seat of our diapers and I
won't remember that and then we'll end
up calling it something shitty do you
know what I mean anyway dude we're gonna
be all these [ __ ] places and I'm
gonna do two shows in Bethlehem
Pennsylvania caching caching and then
Rochester New York and then Royal do
Michigan by the way is like it's going
on in Michigan do it I keep adding shy
love Michigan I love Michigan and it's
fine but I love Michigan because
Michigan keeps on helping the back of
the [ __ ] Brinks truck let me sure try
to go to youtube and do it see if it
works on YouTube
Brinks what no I saw a mute I'm not
[ __ ] dingbat yeah no sound works
period that's good that's great
she's really good so no sound work so
we're gonna go for commencement
so uh all right cool well that's it
we're gonna do like we used to in the
old days but also but also uh yeah so
that's it we're gonna go room Royal Oak
Detroit Michigan New Buffalo Michigan uh
wiser a new buffalo there shouldn't even
be a [ __ ] regular buffalo have you
ever been a buffalo in New York I got
it's fine if you live in Buffalo New
York
honestly it's cool people have to live
everywhere and you know Malaysians grow
and grow and pretty soon you're like
alright [ __ ] it and they find a place
Buffalo and they [ __ ] expand and okay
fine but I just have one question for
people who live in Buffalo oh why yeah
and then the Minneapolis I'm shooting my
special I did my show last night at the
Hollywood improv and I did my hour and
I'm very excited about it and and I I
didn't do it in maybe like a month and I
finally did it now that I'm done with
this movie I'm able to do I'm able to
[ __ ] get the reps in and do my and do
my set before I shoot it and I I did it
last night and I went over oh and I'm
very excited and I got rejuvenated have
you ever been rejuvenated it feels good
man one time with one of my exes she
would be like she would be like let me
let me get a kiss and then I I know I
kiss her and then like a golden one and
then she would be like oh I'm
rejuvenated and that's cute and that's
just a cute story for you dude was it my
ex-wife yes did we get divorced yes am i
a divorcee yes is it weird to think of
that about yourself yes
even at such a young age I'm 39 yeah
it's weird but that's it dude
it's all good man this [ __ ] is real life
and if you're divorced out there cool
divorce has a [ __ ] negative
connotation it's the [ __ ] to be divorced
to do it it really is it really is you
ain't [ __ ] until you're married once and
you divorce once cuz then you know what
the [ __ ] life is all about man you know
what life is when you get divorced dude
you know what marriage is you don't know
what it is how come you never know what
[ __ ] is until it's over you don't you
don't know you ever see a movie and
you're like whoa that movie rips and
then a week later you're like I don't
really remember it it's because you
didn't know what it was until afterwards
baby I know what it is now dude what if
I was saying that and just tears were
streaming down my face so yeah dude but
life continues to rip right it does life
happens
okay now that's something that would
just be on a stupid coffee mug that a
girl would post on Instagram with quote
unquote messy hair and quote unquote no
makeup with her [ __ ] eyes rolled up
to the side just like Monday's that
would be the caption and it would say
life happens in some kind of squiggly
[ __ ] writing with like a stupid
border around it on the coffee mug now
would that be yeah that would be that
would exist life happens but what we
have to remember is once you [ __ ]
past the situation rejuvenation babies
and life rips again life rips again now
could that also be the title of the show
yes will I forget it yes but life rips
again dude and that's why I put these
[ __ ] lifes life rips hoodies and
t-shirts out there that you can [ __ ]
get to support this podcast so we keep
eating so we keep eating dude you want
to get a [ __ ]
you wanna you want to get some merch so
I can keep eating these turkey
sandwiches dude you [ __ ] click the
bye
you click the purchase [ __ ] icon on
my website and it's like I'm practically
going nom nom nom that's it you click it
a matin so you click it and when you
click buy or purchase and you click you
know next day air or whatever the [ __ ]
it is when you click that I want you to
imagine me going nom nom nom
this cult leader [ __ ] is serious
business dude Jared Leto thinks and I
thought I said I wouldn't say his name
and I'm never gonna say I would never
say his name on this podcast but Jared
Leto is not a cult leader
that's a celebrity dude me mmm cult
leader the guys walking around with
robes and [ __ ] he turned me off a robes
man he turned me off her robes dude I
was gonna wear all white and this dude
Jared Leto and I don't even I'm not
gonna say I don't say his name but dude
the [ __ ] fact that that dude is
walking around in white robes like what
[ __ ] this boy was gonna do dude the
youngest man alive me I was gonna make
this cold and this dude walks around but
he's serious about it dude you know what
it's like dude it's like when Tupac had
the [ __ ] again here's what another
reason why I'm just like Tupac dude it's
like when Tupac had the [ __ ] he he
was like obsessed with death and he
wanted to make that album with the death
and [ __ ] and death around the corner and
[ __ ] hustle it on the corner and then
big he came out with ready to die and
Tupac was like what the [ __ ] I was one
that toge I was gonna do all the death
[ __ ] and the biggie was like I don't
give a [ __ ] he did ready to die with the
baby on the cover dude
Jerrod little don't biggie me and I
don't I don't say his [ __ ] name on
this podcast but don't biggie me oh by
the way if you're watching on the
[ __ ] video podcast just so you know
I'm serious I got a [ __ ] thick chain
on I have a thick chain on
serious business dude I have a thick
chain on I had a thin chain but I had to
[ __ ] level up dude because those guys
out there like [ __ ] Jared Leto
floating around and I'm not gonna say
his name but he's floating around in a
[ __ ] robe with a bunch of like fives
by the way you ever you see the people
that are in his cult fives maybe a six
is in there somewhere but dude us we got
tans man everyone's killing it they're
all doing Fitness the guys are prettier
than the girls in our [ __ ] by the way
guys walk around all like the [ __ ]
Persian guy in 300 just like what would
you like to do today those are my dudes
those are my dudes and we're all [ __ ]
and sucking and getting that hedonistic
lifestyle and and we're sitting
indian-style and tall grass and I cannot
[ __ ] believe I am right now saying
all this stuff with two other guys in
this room just straight-faced doing
their own [ __ ]
I haven't get rid of and one fire are
literally staring at their computers
like this emoji let them og with the
[ __ ] straight eyes and the straight
mouth and I'm [ __ ] beings because
then you know why because I'm being
serious because this is a [ __ ]
laughing matter dude I have a [ __ ] if
I take this shirt off and keep the chain
on I swear to god I've done it and
walked around and people literally and
I'm not [ __ ] joking they mistake me
for DMX they go like this is that oh
nevermind and I know what they're
thinking they're thinking is the
lawnmower right next to the tray the
lawnmower right next to the tree my
favorite thing about DMX is this the
[ __ ] melody will be like damn Dane
ain't donate donate donate donate donate
that'll be like the [ __ ] melodic tune
of the thing and the DMX will just
straight up come on and he will go Danny
Danny Danny Danny Danny Danny like hey
dude they're covering that part I swear
to God and it'll be like you could be
blind and if everyone same idea might
say wait you could be blind a bad mess
I'm a lame up there
what's the [ __ ] da max I got to do it
from
phone because we're doing it because I
don't have [ __ ] sound on the goddamn
thing but we're gonna do it do it try it
I'll give it to you give you the
computer okay and while I do it like
this I'll do it on the thing but this is
what DMX dye does you think I'm not who
we be is the one first who we be
DMX first thing that comes up of course
here we go
[Music]
busting a nut oh wow blessing and I
never realized in the beginning of song
you guys oh yeah another one of those
[Laughter]
what doesn't work it'll still okay well
I can't do it because it's gonna [ __ ]
whatever dude I can't do it because it's
gonna flag it it's gonna flag the
[ __ ] thing and then we're not gonna
be able to monetize it for you to a
black people are like people are gonna
congratulations podcast to listen to
[ __ ] who we be from DMX on my [ __ ]
phone that's not even connected to the
source like somebody wants to hear me
going like oh he's busting a nut over
[ __ ] DMX who we be by the way you know
who's doing that who's listening to who
we be anyway you got it I worked on fire
seems to think it's working now so we're
putting it back on dude see this is it
man I get you like the rawness dude
let's see if it works it's not working
all good between its coming something
from the [ __ ] motherboard which means
it's when fires fault which means
obviously he's not changing his name
anytime soon so DMX will do that and and
I'm practically DMX is basically what
I'm saying dude because I got a [ __ ]
chain I wanted to one day be the [ __ ]
shirts off comic this is way before Bert
Kreischer and now I'm like okay well
Bert does it so I wanted to be the ja
rule of comedy as basically what it was
but now Bert does it and I can't do it
and that's fine I'm happy for Bert
honestly I think he's got like a million
followers on the Instagram so that's
great it works now it works now dude it
works now man it [ __ ] works now and
just so you know it worked just to
[ __ ] prove it works right now
yup hell yeah dude
let's get these [ __ ] in let's put
these in cuz I meant to do those from
earlier and let's [ __ ] throw in a
little one of these because I'm going to
do it from earlier and then I also meant
to do one of these a little bit earlier
and I was talking about two pockets so
rude so rude to start a song like that
but life rips and it continues to rip
and that's it and that's it man
so what was I gonna talk about dude I
was where have I been
I was in New Jersey I was in Atlantic
City one more time one more again I was
in Atlantic City and I didn't want to be
in Atlantic City
of course because Atlantic City because
it's Atlantic City I had to go back
because I thought I was done with the
movie and they were like hey you got to
come to do a body scan for visual
effects and I go like this what I said
is a prank I thought was a prank and
they're like they she writes back
negative
oh we're getting oh we're getting a fish
oh dude you're gonna write negative in
an email oh we're getting all business
like all of a sudden because because I
think it's a prank we're getting
business like she writes negative we
need you out here to do the VFX scan and
then she started sounding like Charlie
Brown's teacher do you know why because
all I could hear was my blood I was so
mad I heard my blood you ever get so mad
you hear your blood that's what I was
doing
sizzling that's what I heard I go like
this is somebody cooking bacon and so I
did that and um and I was like well
let's let's [ __ ] and they were like
we gotta come Sunday this is how I did
let me a little taste of me okay I come
here Sunday are they like we won't fly
it 10 a.m. Sunday we'll do the VFX scan
Monday morning and then you can leave
Monday night
so I go like this I'll take the red-eye
I'll take the red-eye I'll land in
Philly drive to AC get there by around
7:00 a.m. do the VFX scan and then I'm
leaving first flight out and they go
like this okay well we might need you
until 3:30 and I go like this Kay I'll
take the 3:30 flight even though there's
a 1250 flight they thought I wouldn't
make it so me old Chris good sport
D'Elia flies over there redeye
did I sleep a wink no why even in first
class what couldn't I do it because I
can't sleep on planes because it was
also the [ __ ] first class where like
the seats are only a little bit
different bigger not differ cuz it's not
a word but I said differ and I don't
know why I mean bigger so the seats were
a little bit differ and so I did it so I
got there
drove 7:00 a.m. got there no one's there
to receive me I don't know where to go
so I go like this where the [ __ ] do I go
snapped at at a deal a little bit was
probably pretty shitty didn't mean to
wasn't his fault but you know what I've
been flying all night I apologized to
him later all good and I feel bad even
still cuz I like that guy he's got a
really kind face and he was really nice
and one of the guys that I connected
with anyway do the VFX can get all
dressed in my [ __ ] gear and I you
know 20 minutes fine then I am done by
9:00 and I go like this I can make the
1250 flight so I get in touch with the
travel agent for production and I say
hey can I uh can I get the 1250 flight
now mind you I've had no sleep I am I'm
a manager Josh Lieberman you know we'll
find a flight you know if there's a seat
on there is he on the plane
Danna right be saying something cool so
try to do it okay so he's is okay so I'm
like you know I'm I set my alarm I'm
gonna go to sleep
imma wake up in an hour I'll check and
see if the flights changed I wake up
flights not changed all good at this
point I'm dreaming man at this point
troll
are bringing me bagels right I'm in my
head I'm out on [ __ ] lala land
I'm hanging out with the Keebler Elf
somewhere okay
so I emailed Josh and I say listen Josh
is probably too late and I email the
travel agent don't change the flight
I'll just go out 3:30 because I'm gonna
[ __ ] drift down and [ __ ] chill
with these Keebler elves and level and a
little bit longer and I'll just fly out
my day shot anyway and Josh says oh [ __ ]
we're gonna dream when Cubans are in
there okay so I said great cut to the ad
knocks on my door and it's 1225 and she
says hey you got to get up because your
rides here for the 3/5 3:30 flight and I
say great ready to go okay so I go
downstairs and as I'm going downstairs
in the elevator I have an email so I
checked email and it's from lo and
behold the travel agent and she says
switched your flight to 1250
[Music]
it's 1225 now I wouldn't have been able
to make that flight if I was at the
airport already
however I'm on I'm getting into the car
to go to the airport and I'm in Atlantic
City and the airport I'm flying out of
[Music]
is in Philadelphia now I'm reading this
email and good thing nobody's telling it
to me because all I can hear is my blood
I'm smelling around for Bacon's
now one time when I was in LA cañada I
used to go to this place that would have
the bomb ass Turkey tuna melt they would
have the bomb s2 in amounts and it was
called burgees and it's still there
because they make the bomb ass turner
mouths and whenever I was in locking out
of visiting my mom I would get the bomb
ass to an amount and one time a kid
named Colin Barnes told me to get bacon
on the tuna-melt and I was like what why
would you [ __ ] something perfect up
that's like eating cheese while you're
getting your dick sucked sure I liked
both of those things but separately is
better okay
and Colin goes like this just try it and
I say alright so I walk up to the
counter and I say hey uh can I get bacon
on my tuna melt and the guy behind the
counter says how many Bacon's and I
think of that every three weeks
so now I'm in the car okay and I call
Josh and he says I got email you know
okay I got the email see there's a
mistake so I say yeah just make sure
that I'm still on the 3:30 flight
because I just got the itinerary that my
flight changed in 20 minutes
ah all right but I think secretly I'm
looking at it wrong when I see this
email I think oh I have to go to the
doctor because I have a tumor pushing up
against my optical nerve
cuz it's scrambling what I'm looking at
I'm looking at 3:30 but it looks like
1250 so I hang up the phone and then
Josh calls me back and it made me stay
and so I'm in 1250 but how far from the
airport and I say it's in Philly I'm not
in Philly I'm just checking your side
you know so I say okay well make sure
she changes it back to 3:30 cuz I'm on
my way now and I don't want to get to
the airport it only happened
I mean alright so so then he calls you
back and he says I just kind of I'm
screaming with them is it like we got
your ticket but it's not first-class
saying where they lost the seat and
everything else was like that scene in
Private Ryan when the guy's looking for
his arm and you just hear
and I'm just and I'm looking for my
itinerary I can't fight you I'm looking
for my itinerary like he's looking for
his arm I'll just get my water bucket
and all of a sudden it comes back in hey
you know I'll call him but I'll be in
there and I click did I get to the
airport and I'm in seat like 4355 Izzie
I didn't even know the plane went that
far by the time I got to the back of the
plane
I was already in Los Angeles so I'm
furious there's nothing I can do I get
to the gate the guy I'm gonna pull this
[ __ ] he said I said yeah as I was
supposed to be in first they lost the
thing and then the thing happened and
then and he goes like this
well I that's full sorry if you want to
go first though there's another flight
the only one left where there's further
first is 9 p.m. and I go like this hey
man it's [ __ ] 1 o'clock what am I
gonna do at the airport in Philly for 8
hours how many times am I gonna [ __ ]
lap Hudson news I mean like [ __ ]
goddamn Hudson news I've ever seen the
Hudson news out of the airport the [ __ ]
get it together dude go outside Hudson
news so I [ __ ] get on the point I'm
dude I'm hearing bacon sizzle I'm
hearing how many Bacon's sizzle dude I
don't even know how many Bacon's it's
are sizzling and my [ __ ] head right
now in my ears so I get to the [ __ ]
plane and just to make matters worse in
first they got the lay down badge dude
but here daddy is all propped up like a
goddamn praying mantis
I bought even bought one of those
[ __ ] neck pillow things I'm propped
up like a prick like I'm [ __ ] Stephen
talking just praying praying mantis and
the [ __ ] video doesn't even work the
[ __ ] back of the seat video so I'm
just guessing I'm doing for five hours
thinkin I know these are [ __ ] rich guy
problems but I don't give a sh dude
here's the other thing this was this
twist to the knife I'm talking to one of
the cast members and they say you didn't
do the VFX thing in Albuquerque that had
it there for two months I flew there for
I'm a businessman and you know how jay-z
is like I'm not a businessman I'm a
businessman I'm just a businessman okay
make no mistake I'm not a businessman
I'm businessman so that was my [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] my topsy-turvy adventure I was
in Atlantic City for [ __ ] six hours
10 hours there 10 hours back including
the drive time even more probably anyway
dude let's pay some bills my bookie I
don't know about you guys but for me a
game is ten times more exciting when I'm
putting my money on it
dar dar sometimes I have a gut feeling
about a matchup and sometimes I'm just
being on my team I'm just betting on my
team because their team regardless
whether you've been betting for years
you're ready to play for the first time
my bookie is your best best bet this
season if the kind of guy who likes to
bed a little to win Allah try a parlay
for instance if you like a couple of the
big favorites this week parlays are
perfect because they let you back
multiple times together for a much
bigger payout so if you're gonna bet
this season do the smart thing and go to
my bookie dot AG because no one gives
you more waves to win football season
MLB playoffs NBA NHL come on get off the
sidelines get to the action my bookie
if you join right now my bookie will
double your first deposit isn't that
crazy
my bookie AG use promo code Congrats to
activate the offer that's promo code
Congrats visit my bookie dot AG today
you play you win you get paid
what actually makes a better toothbrush
industrial strength power claims of
miraculous trendy ingredients multiple
modes if you ask your dentist they'll
they'll tell you it's less about the
brush and more about how you use it
that's why quip was created by dentists
and product designers to focus on what
actually matters for your oral health
healthier habits equip sensitive
vibrations with a bolt with a built-in
timer guide gentle brushing for the
dentist recommended 2 minutes with 30
second pulses ensuring an even clean
clip automatically delivers brush heads
to you every three months for clean new
bristles right on schedule
the sleek intuitive design is simple to
use and it comes with a travel cap that
doubles as a mirror mount these
thoughtful features make brushing
something you actually want to do twice
everyday quip starts at just 25 dollars
and you'll get your first refill free at
get clip comm / Congrats this is a
simple way to support our show and start
brushing better but you have to go to
get qu IP dot-com / Congrats to get your
first refill free go right now to get qu
IP comm / Congrats so yeah that's what
we're doing dude that's what we're doing
oh and I hit DMX by mistake and I hit
deep I love it do it okay that's a
really really bad way to say English
English but Moe so is what I said but
[Music]
and I keep chilling and I stay drinking
[ __ ] look for even though this is
Perrier these thin cans man they got to
go though it's like what am i [ __ ]
holding a [ __ ] this [ __ ] thing make
the Canes bigger I don't like this
bitch-ass [ __ ] it look like a keychain
Perrier is killing it with the little
thin ash cans though they're for like a
[ __ ] evil villain a theme if female
you evil villain that's a second mm
you'll have to kill him
[Music]
anyway when I got to the [ __ ] Airport
finally this chick this girl who had to
be 22
you know people come up to me sometimes
whatever I'm ready for it and [ __ ] I see
him come I see you coming by the way
from like you're not being sneaky you
know people think they're like Cato and
I and the guy and the this girl goes
like this ah and I go hey
and she says beer pong and I go well
what the [ __ ] is gonna be happening at
this point from now on what kind of
reaction damn I gonna have to [ __ ]
drum up she goes beer pong and I and I
say huh and she says I met you last
night during beer pong and I say no not
me
and she says yeah it was you and
everybody's listening and I'm sure some
of those people are like this idiot
got it wrong she does doesn't realize
that that's the comedian and she maybe
recognizes him that way and is confusing
someone else's [ __ ] janky face
playing beer pong maybe she was drunk
and now she thinks Cristal Chris D'Elia
was playing beer pong with her by the
way there are some people that think
that but the people who don't know who I
am are looking at me like oh this
[ __ ] guy doesn't want to seem like he
was playing beer pong with a 22 year old
so now it looked like a [ __ ] creep
she goes beer pong 22 year old and I say
huh
39 year old and she says Mitchell last
night playing beer pong and I say one me
and she says yeah it was dude quit
blowing my fake cover it wasn't me first
of all I would never play beer pong dude
if I
drink I first of all I've never drank
period ever end of story
full stop do I like when people say that
no but full stop uh I've never drank
okay so I know I didn't play beer pong
even if I did if I drink every day like
a [ __ ] fish I would never play beer
pong uh you know why cuz I don't need a
reason to drink if I'm gonna drink I'm
just gonna [ __ ] put the [ __ ] to my
mouth and then ingest it in my body
you're not gonna try and get a bull I
got to get a harder give me all the
alcohol put it inside me and let me be
drunk as [ __ ] beer pong you know I
wouldn't even play ping pong how about
that you gonna give me a paddle now this
bitch-ass little thing no way dude the
only thing a paddle should be is on is
connected to a [ __ ] key to get into a
gasps gasps [ __ ] station bathroom you
ever see the prank on YouTube I don't
know who it is but it's some [ __ ]
show where they put the [ __ ] keys on
funny things in the gas station and at
one time they [ __ ] and they kept
putting on like big-ass things and the
person that's like bring the big-ass
thing and the last one was they put the
key on a cat and they were like here you
go and the guy had to carry the cat to
undo the key was attached to the cat's
[ __ ] collar and he had to undo the
thing and then piss with the cat and the
cat oh man that was hilarious but guess
what it still wasn't as funny as the
[ __ ] Brian Collins Instagram where he
says I'm the man dragon dude I did that
I put that I put that up last night holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] man
let's play it cuz that [ __ ] Bryan Callen
is the biggest idiot of all time I can't
even believe this [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
let's go to his thing did okay like let
me just this okay so yo I was eating
with my buddies
alright and Bryan Callen shows up and
we're all eating together and then he
leaves El Rio leaf right
we're all laughing outside of the diner
as we do we [ __ ] laugh outside of the
diner cuz once you eat and you're done
it's not over [ __ ] the fat lady
hasn't sung yet you go outside and you
think you know you do the thing really
oh man uh you do that dude because I'm
almost 40 you do that you go uh some
[ __ ] gets a toothpick because he
thinks he needs it you know oh you do
that you know you go out forgets [ __ ] no
Larry's in there you know and so Callen
leaves because he likes to he loves to
pretend like yes [ __ ] to do I [ __ ] 3
I am even though he doesn't and he
leaves and he gets goes walks over to
his car and this happens okay let me
just [ __ ] pull it up again so I can
play it from from the beginning this
happens stays far away me and my other
two buddies dyrus guy and Craig yo hey
that's me obviously what's up Bryan your
[ __ ] huh you're a [ __ ] okay so he's
far away now he drives over his car
stylin
he's tesla [ __ ] rolls over like it's
a kitty cat okay
pulls up I'm shooting and I'm good yeah
tonight my comedy this is what I do
crowds ready they you know why they call
me the man dragons
[Applause]
[Laughter]
does this u-turn illegally peace out
guys
drives away [ __ ] zips by and then has
to stop at a red light dude let me tell
you something right now there's nothing
that's ever been funnier than that okay
he's 52 bro he's 52 go to my Instagram
page and you can see it it's the last
thing I posted he just goes one that one
god damn he's funny man I'll [ __ ] him up
I will dude I'll [ __ ] him up till I get
my money right load a little oh it's
dirty crew I don't know what the words
are and I don't give a [ __ ] I don't
[ __ ] do the words of the song I make
my own [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I feel it out dude I scat I scat
over the guy in the real world that
[ __ ] scattered I die scat dude
la-da-da wait till I get my money right
Lolo it's soo decruz browning Yoli
rollio
wait till I get my money right you
little away
it's Terry Crews bow now new yoli Rolly
uh-oh
Brownell yep that's it dude [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh man I Love You Tube when you'll
be like wait till I get my money right I
go to type in and I go wait till and it
goes and then it the suggestion thing
says wait till I get my money right and
then I hit the spacebar and it says wait
till my father gets home just keep it
the way it was I don't want to listen to
[ __ ] wait to look at my father give
my money right
[Music]
Yolo
it's Terry Crews totally ugly uh-oh
[Music]
Brownell nil dude I gotta come up with a
[ __ ] lounge acapella [ __ ] I gotta do
it dude I don't know what I'm doing I
gotta do it the first comment is lalala
wait till I get my money right cool
worth it worth it feel the pressure
under more scrutiny um oh cool it keeps
scrolling even though I'm not hitting it
let's blame it on one fire um anyway ads
here we go my babies you guys know I
like sneakers and shoes I use the app
goat to get all my stuff it's authentic
and they make sure of it if you're buy
stickers online there's more than the
coin flips chance that the shoe you're
looking at is fake how can you be sure
it's real well goat takes care of that
goat comm is the safest way to buy and
sell authentic sneakers online they're
the largest marketplace in the world for
authentic Easy's Jordans and over
600,000 sneaker listings they've made
the whole process frictionless and
trustworthy they do it by only accepting
sellers with the best reputation and by
verifying all sneakers to ensure their
authenticity for the buyers every detail
is inspected every time I get my shows
shoes from goat it's all a hundred
percent real half a million stickers on
the platform that means they have the
sneakers that you want and ten million
users you won't find better prices for a
verified 100% authentic stickers
everywhere or anywhere else find the
perfect 100% authentic sneaker at Goat
calm / Congrats that's goat comm /
Congrats plus you'll also be supporting
our show but you've got to go right now
before the sneakers you want are gone
when you go to goat comm / Congrats
spelled Geo eighty comm / congrats
congratulations is brought to you by the
cash app the official app of the log
cabin wait till I get my money right
Yolo
we taking over one city at a time I sing
beautifully dude we taking over one city
at a time we takin over one silly at a
time something on rim pin throne a room
day and rent them throwing it they
probably flag that for [ __ ] monetary
value dude because that's how good it is
rim from thin limped in Tony room thinly
with taken over one city at a time
because I know people will be like why
would I listen to the DJ Khaled song
when I can hear Chris's acapella [ __ ]
kick-ass version we taking oo-over right
it's like a mirror whoa and it's [ __ ]
looking back at me whoa it's like a
mirror yeah sure basic JT try a little
harder it's like a mirror whoa it's
looking back at me so basic making the
turkey sandwich whoa help me it's out of
two breads whoa [ __ ] cheese put it in
my mother statue and in this lunch wall
hell yeah babies what we doing do it
what we doing life rips and dude whether
you got dance or not life rips is a mind
state dude you got some [ __ ] dance in
your bank account life could still rep
you can have dents aplenty and still
[ __ ] rip life anew [ __ ] how about
when they say I tore me a new [ __ ] I
don't like that either man anyway dude
it's all good Oh what else should we
talk about man what happened in the news
I saw a [ __ ] what happen in the news
I saw the [ __ ] people were some of
the Academy members for [ __ ] the
Oscars I didn't see the movie yet Joker
but
want to see it I'm dying to [ __ ] see
it looks looks awesome some of them were
like well it's controversial so we
shouldn't even some of that Academy
rumors like we shouldn't even consider
it for winning an award like what dude
are you kidding me you know how many
[ __ ] contra yeah controversial movies
are usually not good they're all [ __ ]
the best movies are controversial
they're dealing with real issues they
soap how movies aren't changing the
[ __ ] world is changing and then you're
[ __ ] up art how about that so you know
chill on that because it's a movie about
a goddamn evil villain that fights
Batman and is a clown it's like a mirror
whoa and it's looking back at me whoa
how's it go now they don't say [ __ ]
in that song right it's like I'm a
[ __ ] mirror whoa and I'm staring back
at me and I can't [ __ ] believe I'm
staring in a mirror oh whoa [ __ ] looking
back at me whoa donkey balls [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] that's her ah imagine if Justin
Timberlake made a song and it came out
like that and and I would be the [ __ ]
I would wait in line to get the [ __ ]
hard copy dude and they don't even do
hard copies anymore
uh I saw Jessica Biel on a flight once
she's married to him she's really pretty
oh good oh good
loosey-goosey silly ass silly goose time
man
you go to your podcast for your [ __ ]
NPR [ __ ] and everything else but you
come here for a silly guy damn good time
and that's it that's it how about this
man teen girls join forces to convince
people that eating used tampons is
normal vice dude that's a vice article
what's up with Vice what was the other
one the Vice one that I was [ __ ]
looking at in the group text you know
which one what the [ __ ] was it no oh
wait no the one that was said - oh that
that that minimalism was against gays or
something vice dude just trying to get
some clicks I sat down with a guy who's
got a minimalist view in the world turns
out he's homophobic nice
what vice will be like you know I don't
know Weiss will come out with a thing
like bread normalizes fruit and you're
like what if you're just like a lot we
can't normalize fruit bread normalizes
fruit and you're like k and then some
guy with a beard and tattoos will just
be like well it's true bread normalizes
fruit and then [ __ ] it people will
just be like I mean I can't argue with
them I gotta be an in cell I got a star
I gotta [ __ ] give up and he's sort of
[ __ ] even just jerking off just I
gotta be an in cell I don't know what
else yes that's about it should we do
any kind of things do we have like miss
connections or do we have questions what
do we got here oh oh wow dude whoa first
of all can each Chris Chris Taliah this
by John Lindros at true underscore baby
97 cool Chris actor say what do you
think of the name of Kenny Chesney's new
tour okay those of you that don't know
what it is I'll tell you right now
it's called chillax off' ocation dude
and let me tell you something
tor 2020 starring Kenny Chesney course
chillax off' occation florida georgia
line course an Old Dominion and Michael
Franti and spearhead
dude let's just break that down
chillax off' occation now if I hear
somebody say chillax quarter lunch I'm
out I don't deal with you in a
respectful way anymore unless you're
like a housewife because then I get it
you're not hip to what's hip but if
you're just like a dude and you say like
yeah the bros are coming over to [ __ ]
chillax a little bit uh you know we're
just gonna chillax all right I don't do
the two words that are added into one
word
I don't do the [ __ ] ginormous bro
that makes me want to [ __ ] visit
fantabulous see ya
so chillax No okay if
occasion okay that's another two words
that's actually maybe three words
together its Californication keishon so
that's like vacation
if chillax if vacation so is there's
actually three letters in there that
don't even need really to make it to
make me stop hearing bacons chillax
ocation would make me hear less Macon's
right but chillax if okay it's like
saying like you know doing the thing
where it's like when people think that
it's funny to say breasteses still even
though david alan grier made that [ __ ]
funny and [ __ ] 1943 and then it was
funny for about ten years because david
alan grier did it so stop doing it now
but chillax off' ocation is then four
words together but they all multiply
each other so let's put it this way it's
not four words it's four times four or
some [ __ ] so that's 16% of helmand
sixteen times how many Bacon's I'm
hearing promoted by Sponsor blue chair
Bay which I don't even know what it is
dude Kenny Chesney for real this is
something I know bought an island how
you might infer he must be so rich let's
look at his [ __ ] net worth right here
even though this is so wrong you could
look up any celebrity's net worth and
it's mostly wrong but it's still
something I go by because the internet
said it net worth a hundred and ninety
million and he's probably my age right
who is the richest country singer in the
world Toby Keith 500 million yep dude
bro five hundred million for singing
about your dog you note I mean Dolly
Parton's four hundred Shinya Twain three
hundred fifty million honestly that
doesn't present
much George Strait 300 million Kenny
Rogers 250 million Taylor Swift
wellokay 200 million Garth Brooks
hundred fifty fifty million Johnny Cash
120 million well I know there's a
problem there because he's not spending
any other right now
Brooks Wow Garth Brooks is not the Toby
Keith and I don't even know if Toby
Keith walked through the door I would
straight up be like hey man can I help
you I wouldn't know who he is
Toby be Keith let's look him up Toby
Keith Morrison Toby Keith bro let's look
him up five hundred million dollars yeah
if this guy walked through the door
wouldn't know he was wow he looks
severely different in all of these
Google Images whoa he's just got a
shapeshifter
I mean god this guy's wide huh he
literally is so white it looks like
somebody would be like yeah my friend's
a black guy and he would be like Oh what
maybe like a black guy he goes like this
sorry I don't follow and be like what do
you mean he's like what are you talking
about he says oh but he's a black guy
and he would be like yeah no I know what
you're saying but I can't understand
what do you mean he was like we know
it's like a he's like African American
descent like he's he says and then Toby
Keith who would say what you say uh I'm
sorry I don't know what you don't get he
says what are you saying you're saying
he says well you know how you're white
until we keep if you're like wow yeah
you goddamn right I'm white and you'd be
like would you chill yeah no I
understand and I'm white with as well
and he was like of course you are and
then you'd be like okay well my friend
is not white and then Toby Keith looks
like you would when that point that
public you
laughs for [ __ ] for three minutes and
then he would be like ah wiping tears
away from his [ __ ] cowboy eyes and
just be like oh and then he would say
like well would it what is he he's in
he's black and he's like like a black
like he's the color he was like well
he's kind of brownish actually you know
I'd be like so he's a brown guy and he'd
be like no he said have you ever seen
somebody not white and then Toby kebbel
left for [ __ ] six more minutes and
went cry laughing and then focused our
way yeah what are you talking about man
and he would just put a start be like
they don't to get they own they get a o-
no name on to get on [ __ ] do name down
take it down baby I didn't know named it
my dog and my house they only get on the
damn time playing radio dude
country songs love singing about playing
the radio it's unreal how many country
songs like I turned the radio on skip it
bro you're like a [ __ ] chick eating
sushi talking about sushi see ya
you're boring don't talk about the thing
you're doing talk about something else
while you're doing the thing this way
you cover more ground and you can have a
personality every [ __ ] country singer
is just like we turn the radio on
sitting back yeah drip top down and we
run into the freeway [ __ ] 91 don't
just name freeways and oh the breeze
feels I don't give a [ __ ] how the breeze
feels the breeze feels how the breeze
feels clouds come in bring become rayon
rayon become brown brown bro
I'd much rather listen to something like
[ __ ] wait till I get my money right
little Rolo it's runny Cruz Brunel nuno
de Leo leo
[Music]
[ __ ] that is the [ __ ] compared to do
never never never naked Oh [ __ ] never
know what you're like certification is
what we're doing a mile in getting my
[ __ ] private jet and it's sponsored
by Blue Chair Bay and Florida Georgia
line gonna be there and they will
literally be nobody in this [ __ ]
concert fan or artist that's not wearing
a tank top and [ __ ] shorts with cargo
pants on even though shirt should never
have cargo pants because y'all should
never have cargo pockets because shorts
are shorts and pants you have oh [ __ ]
cuz it's like do you want fabric or not
don't just take the fabric off your
shins and then put more fabric above
your knee they create a pocket no name-
[ __ ] name on it if Toby Keith walked
into a [ __ ] for real Popeyes Chicken
he would be like oh these people dude
[ __ ] my [ __ ] thing went out he could
walk into [ __ ] uh what's the [ __ ]
Boulevard Alvarado Boulevard and just
see a whole bunch of Mexicans and Toby
kid would drive through his Drive would
drive to anybody later for a second roll
down these windows man you see that
thing next to that frilly donkey house
that's hanging right there the pinata
sir though
what what did you say
did the pinata the pit ah I'm talking
about the frilly donkey there the
colorful one who are those people
smacking that thing kids I mean what is
the color of them we're late let's go if
Toby Keith stepped into a Glendale
Galleria he would be like oh sorry man
let me just get on OC I came here to fix
my phone in this kiosk but what do you
do sir you're a person right okay
like a regular person what color are you
and what is the chain man and the what
is out with all that hair you're from
Huerta where in America is that April
it's not in America man hey first of all
stand back bro April don't come in my
face like that bro you're yelling at me
right now man and the tip of your cowboy
hat is hitting my [ __ ] eyebrows I
gotta get out of here Manny
y'all are too much man y'all too much
then their nicotine nicotine nicotine in
here near near near near near near we're
you not a
it everybody loves everyone here I'm
gonna make anyone anyone in there no no
no no I saw a brown guy and another
brown kid and then a brown guy don't get
big no one in there they were and why
they were getting oh no they were
another color and they're known anyone
in there and and my wife friend assured
me that they were still people now look
at the only thing gonna do [ __ ] never
no never no never no now I said whoa are
you real person down there kneeling
there no no no no no but it's not my
fault because I'm so white I'm
translucent and I'm doing down there no
no I got a beard of course and my cowboy
hat goes down in the front but up on the
sides down to get down there down [ __ ]
I have five hundred million dollars and
I'll never seen someone knocked and
don't get in there noon never seen
someone who's darker than a 10 why I
don't get anyone even though I don't
even get ten I get pink I'm that color
of balls doing a gig down there don't
know Doh doh-doh I'm the color of under
turkeys beak they were naked
[Music]
[Laughter]
he wears pants 30% of the time dude he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he's literally
taking rides in a car and got out of his
house
with no pants on got in the car no pants
drove to Starbucks had somebody get out
getting hurt so much [ __ ] went back
this house all with no pants on duties
for sure done it doing he's for sure
done it holy [ __ ] [ __ ] do it ah
goddamn it
I've never seen a guy be [ __ ] so
good-looking and also so not
good-looking it's unreal this guy's
great he's great he's great he's the
Mickey Rourke of [ __ ] country singer
Mickey Rourke was like the handsomest
most [ __ ] and also looks like a
um all right dude I'm out of here man
[ __ ] thanks for bringing chillax a
vacation to my [ __ ] attention dude oh
[ __ ]
how many denim shirts you think he has
huh all right dude else all right did I
write it I'll see him [ __ ] dude I am
a madman thank God I was seeing I see in
Santa Barbara
I see in Reverse Odyssey in San Diego I
see you in Foxwoods I see in Bethlehem I
see in Rochester Royal Oak New Buffalo
Minneapolis the taping of my of my
Netflix special Minneapolis Minneapolis
that's Tampa Florida
I can't wait to Minneapolis Tampa
Florida Melbourne Florida Hollywood
Florida El Paso Houston Puri Illinois
[ __ ] Chicago Illinois New Year's Eve
come see me in Chicago my Vegas and
celebrate the New Year with me anyway
dude you guys are great
download download the cash app for free
on the App Store or Google Play market
and support the show we got new merch we
got life of rips hoodies and t-shirts
those are going bloggers and all the
other stuff for sale thanks so much you
guys
and remember [ __ ] just I don't know
it doesn't matter good I'll check you
guys later
[Music]